I was holding online office hours and my
grad students the other night and we
were going over how to look at a
structure in Pinal
when you don't know very much about
what's going on we were looking at an
enzyme and I basically showed them how
to make an active site with just
sequence information and I thought that
I had come up with some pretty good
codes and methods to do this and I
wanted to share it with the world so
here we go when we're in PI mole we can
open files in many ways but one way is
to tell pi x and we're going to grab the
structure to AC e so there it loaded it
up and this is acetylcholinesterase
bound to acetylcholine acetylcholine
esterase is found between neurons and
the synapse where it's responsible for
breaking down the neurotransmitter
acetylcholine when it's time to stop a
signal from being transmitted from one
neuron to the other so here this is the
actual molecule that is the
neurotransmitter and we have our
structure here now I'm not sure exactly
how this will look when you open your
file so it might be a cartoon it might
be lines and so you can use these
buttons over here just to show the
structure in whatever way you want so
this rendering here or the way this is
shown with the curlicues and the sheets
this is the cartoon so I'm showing the
cartoon right now and if you needed to
do this add it on because yours came up
in lines so let me just show you what it
might look like they may have upgraded
it but mine used to open like this and
so you might want to go to show as
cartoon and we had a little molecule in
there when we started but we're not
seeing it now but I'm going to show you
how to get back to that and how to make
an active site pretty quickly without
using the paper so here's our 3d model
of our protein and first thing I want
you to do is go to display and show your
sequence
these are all the amino acid residues
and they're one letter codes and this is
a continuous chain and each chain that
is continuous has no breaks in the code
notice these are all right side by side
but once we get to the point where
there's a ligand so acetylcholine bound
in the active site of this enzyme we can
click on that and show it here and it's
not actually showing up it's just
showing as these little dots but we may
we click this and it made a selection
and we want to preserve this selection
so we can keep operating on it later to
do that you have to rename the selection
so go here and here's where we're
renaming it and I'm going to call it a
CH so it's renamed and now that's my
selection if I click on anything else
it makes a new selection so I am
interested in showing this active site
without reading the paper say for some
reason maybe you don't have access to
the paper it's from a journal that you
can't get so you can't look at what they
said the active site residues were or
perhaps you're just looking at quite a
few crystal structures quickly and you
want to decide if this is something
you're gonna model further so let's see
how we can do this now you can change a
lot in Primal you can change your
background color to why you can do that
using all these buttons you can change
your colors of the protein over here
I always color by element because then
we have our CPK coloring shown that's
where nitrogen is blue oxygen is red and
so if you use this color by element you
can change the color I actually have a
PI multi sheet that I keep on my desktop
because I use it a lot and on there I
have a code that helps me display this
so that it's easier for colorblind
people to use so I'm gonna go ahead and
just paste that in and it kind of
changes my my Gila sees here there they
have this nice Ridge on
and it sets a color scheme so see up
here it's setting all these colors to
colors that are better for colorblind
people and I'm going to post a link in
the video description so that you can
access these and this could be the first
thing you do and it'll set up your
structure quite pretty now I want to
make sure that I'm using the colors from
this so I have a cheat sheet for
commands for codes and so I'm going to
just color everything this blue color or
cyan make sure it's the right side and
it doesn't look like it change too much
so maybe it was already set to that but
I just wanted to make sure now I have
acetylcholine here that's bound to this
and there's all these OHS these are just
the water molecules that are in the
structure and this is my only ligand so
this is a pretty easy structure to look
at because we have the acetylcholine
here so I am going to show this because
the typical way is to look at a cartoon
of the protein and then your small
organic molecule shown in sticks so you
can see all of the atoms it's made of so
I'm going to show sticks now and then
I'm going to click away or try to click
away and zoom the active site so the
contrast isn't great because this is the
same color as the protein and so it's
kind of blending in a little so I'm
gonna get a different color for my cheat
sheet that I keep on my desktop and
let's do something that stands out quite
a lot maybe a magenta so I'm gonna use
this code util cBAM and so notice in
these codes it's just this last letter
that changes here and whoops I'm going
to just click off that and I want to say
that I only want to color my ligand that
color so I'm gonna put a CH because
that's what I called it here so that
changes this to magenta maybe that's not
the best color choice because the red is
a little hard to see so I'm just gonna
go with maybe yellow instead so let's
I'm gonna use my arrow keys and go up
and actually all I have to change in the
here is this why so I just used the
arrow keys on my keyboard up arrow goes
back to your last command so let's
change that and it changes it
beautifully
now I want to look at the active site
and so the amino acid residues that are
around this that are potentially having
interactions that help it find or do
catalysis the ones that are involved in
the chemical reaction of breaking this
bond right here so what I'm going to do
is use a code that I use a lot and I'll
explain it I'm gonna copy/paste it
because once you find a good code make
yourself a little cheat sheet like this
if you think it'll be useful you can use
it all the time this is going to allow
me to show the sticks by the residue so
the amino acid residues that are all
within 5 angstroms which is actually a
pretty big space of my selection which
is a CH let me explain to you the magic
and my number 5 that I chose so hydrogen
bonds are usually anywhere we measure
them from the center of one atom to the
center of another so the nucleus the
nuclei distance apart and when you
measure that in angstroms in PI mole the
distance of a hydrogen bond is usually
2.8 to maybe about 3.4 angstroms
ionic interactions can be a little
shorter and then London forces or van
der Waals interactions between nonpolar
chains those are usually in the 3.8 to
4.2 range so this is 5 angstroms it's a
little bigger than that so we might be
able to see some more distant residues
in the active site and so we're not
limiting ourselves to everything that
has an interaction but we're limiting
ourselves to things that are pretty
close to this acetylcholine so I'm gonna
go ahead I don't want that little box
popped up when I do this I'm gonna enter
that command and bam there are all the
residues so we're getting really close
already what I'm going to do now we can
show and hide different elements of this
structure as we're working on it and I'm
going to go up to 2 8
and hide just the cartoon because I want
to show these sticks because they
actually didn't make a selection so if I
delete this selection this is just from
before these are not defined as any
selection I just show the sticks and it
doesn't pop up here but now that I've
just showed these kind of floating
around in space without the rest of the
protein I can click on them individually
making a selection and this is going to
allow me to rename the selection and
have all of these residues within 5
angstroms as a selection that I can
operate on so just spin it around
yep see I missed some over here so once
everything is highlighted now we can
rename the selection and we're gonna
call this active so that's my active
site and I'm gonna go ahead and zoom on
the active site so it Orient's
everything in the middle and makes my
turning point the center of this active
site so I'm turning around the center
anything you zoom it'll like focus in on
that because sometimes you try to turn
the protein and it really spins around
wildly because you're focused on a part
that's not the initial center point
alright so that's pretty great I have
all the residues that could be in the
active site shown now and now I want to
show any interactions that this ligand
the weak interactions that it might be
making to any of these active site
residues there's a really easy way to do
this so here's my acetylcholine my
ligand go to actions and find polar
contacts and I'm going to show them to
any atoms when I do that I can see and
let me just color these polar contacts
so it comes up as his own selection
which is very convenient and I guess
I'll use orange for this maybe light
orange to show these actually maybe
maybe magenta would be good here because
it'll have a nice contrast so let me
make sure I'm on the right selection
magenta magenta oh yeah that's that's
awesome that shows up real well so we
can see
that this oxygen atom here is having
polar contact so hydrogen bonds and
these are actually not side chains there
are backbone atoms of the protein and
that might be hard to see unless we go
back and show our cartoon again notice I
didn't do this show as well talk about
that in a minute but show the cartoon
and so we can see that these atoms are
actually in this chain of this loop here
and there within this the curlicues of
this helix so these are actually making
up the backbone over here this is a
histidine and if you didn't know that
you could click here a little blue line
lights up in the sequence and you just
run over until you're in it and you can
see that's the letter H and hopefully
you know your one letter amino acid
codes and if not you can go look that up
there's also different ways you can
display the sequence to view it in the
three letter codes but I like to use the
one letter codes because I explained
before you can see a break in the code
to find your ligands and that's really
convenient to me so now I've found these
polar contacts but there's something
really weird going on because I have
this one polar contact going off into
nowhere
and I'm gonna go ahead and just hide the
cartoon for another minute so I can deal
with this now this isn't going to
anything visible and it's probably going
to one of these water molecules so a
quick command for that to show the water
molecules is to show non-bonded and
that'll bring up these little asterisks
that are your water molecules there and
so here I have one so one of my contacts
is is two this water molecule actually
and let's see are there any others that
I miss no everything else seems to be
connecting to a residue and so I maybe
want to rename this selection now this
one water molecule and I'll just call it
active water so active site water that's
a good
enough name and if I wanted to I could
now display this in different ways by
maybe showing the dots are shown right
now but I could show the spheres for
this one water molecule showing the
whole big surface of it and yeah I think
that's good for now you can resize these
if you want smaller water molecules in
your image now we've done a pretty good
job now I'm gonna go ahead and hide
non-bonded so that those go away for now
we have our active water that we've
looked at separately and so I have that
shown so showing these polar contacts I
found out there's a polar contact to a
water and the active site and if I
wanted to see what this water molecule
was contacting I could use my command
from before that shows the residues
around it and so if I wanted to do that
which I might as well just show you very
quickly so I want to show the residues
show the sticks of the residues all
around my water molecule now I'm gonna
go ahead and say active underscore water
and let's see if anything else shows up
oh cool so we have another one I wonder
if this is making a hydrogen bond to
this and I could find that out by
showing the polar contacts to my active
water so actions find polar contacts but
there's another way I could do it and
I'm going to show you that now this is
the wizard and so we're gonna use this
measurement wizard so we turn it on and
it comes up right here we're gonna
measure distances and create a new
object for every distance that we create
we can also click on here and merged
measurements with previous if we're
making a lot of measurements and want
them to show up as one selection so I'm
going to see if this here so I'm
clicking on the first atom is in a
probable hydrogen bond with this and
when I click I can see this is 3.6
angstroms away so it's a little far but
it could be involved in a hydrogen bond
they eat things in the active site are
kind of they can move around a little
bit so maybe this crystal structure
captured this a little bit further away
it's a weak interaction at best but this
could be kind of flexible in actual 3d
space so we have to keep that in mind so
I'm going to go ahead and say I'm done
with this for a second
and I can of course rename this to
something more memorable so with the
action button measure one action rename
and I'll call this bond to water and
this right over here this nitrogen is
actually bonded to four groups one two
three four all those yellow carbons 1 2
3 4 and that makes this nitrogen of
acetylcholine actually formerly
positively charged and cations like this
actually have great Van der Waals
interactions with the PI system of
aromatic rings aromatic rings have
electrons that are above and below the
ring and electrons are negative so they
have lots of negative charge so this
group has all this positive charge from
nitrogen being a cation so the whole
thing over here has a lot of positive
charge smeared on it so I want to see I
have a bunch of aromatic amino acids
over here here's a phenylalanine if we
didn't know that was phenylalanine we
could go find the F in the sequence and
then I have this one over here this is a
tryptophan and if I didn't know that I
could go over there where it showed up
and see its letter which is w1 letter
code but I want to see if these are
close enough to be making Vander Waals
contacts and potentially binding this
positively charged group with the PI
cloud so what I'm going to do is take
pick one of these methyl groups on here
and measure that distance the nitrogen
is kind of buried in the middle of the
molecule so we'll see if these are in
proximity to have hydrophobic contacts
so we'll go back to the measurement
wizard wizard measurement
and I am going to merge my measurements
this time if you make a mistake though
you have to delete your whole object so
I'm gonna try really hard to do this
right so we're gonna click on one of
these methyls and see this is 4.1
angstroms that's that's in range of
having an interaction of Van der Waals
interaction and so that's to this carbon
over here we could do some other sample
points about 4.1 from all of these
I wonder it's kind of hard to see in
space wonder if any of these other atoms
is closer yeah about the same and let's
see how this guy measures up over here
oh that's a little bit far so I wouldn't
probably want to show that if I was
showing my active site so I think I have
to delete if I did the leat the last
object I delete the whole thing so let's
just put up a couple sample measurements
again very quickly or slowly depending
on how I get this or Hanten so this one
has some nice close contacts and now
let's reposition this and check out this
phenylalanine because this is an
aromatic ring and so it has pi electrons
kind of above and below like swirling
around doing resonance and so let's see
this methyl looks like it might be close
hey three point seven so this
phenylalanine could be very important
and stabilizing that cation in the
active site and helping it to bind
there's one more thing I want to show
you that's really neat about this active
site before I show you about the show as
command and that's this right here our
ligand acetylcholine and let me just
show sorry let me just hide the water
I'll hide everything for a moment and
let's just turn off this measurement I
can just unclick it here this yellow
stuff is our ligand and this cyan or
blue is our enzyme so the O H of this
serine residue actually at
attacks the carbonyl of an ester in
acetylcholine and makes this covalent
bond before the molecule breaks apart
the enzyme releases it and can break up
another molecule of acetylcholine
so this crystal structure actually
captured acetylcholine esterase in the
act of catalysis it's actually
covalently bonded we can see that
because the chain is continuous not like
these weak interactions that we had to
measure ourselves within the active site
or have pi mol display by showing the
polar contacts so now we have a pretty
decent idea of the active site if you
wanted to measure distances to these
other residues you could to see if
they're close but we have a pretty good
picture now I'm gonna go ahead and turn
off the measurements because I want to
show you just one final thing I'm going
to show the cartoon again so the cartoon
of this whole protein if I could find it
there we are so now we can see our where
our active site really lies and it's in
the center of this protein notice
there's this clipping and you can turn
that on and off I'm like putting my
fingers up and down two fingers on my
trackpad or if we want to just be sure
the clipping is off we'll just say
nothing it kind of shaves away the
protein a little bit at a time so you
can better view things so you're taking
a little chunk off of the protein so
that's the clipping there but if we go
up here if you ever feel like if
something seems chopped off go ahead and
check your clipping so nothing and now
we see our active site and kind of can
tell where it's positioned in the whole
enzyme here and now I'm gonna zoom in a
little bit and I want to get a good
unobscured view maybe I do need to put
on just a little clipping to show you
what I want to show you so here all of
our active site residues are shown as
both cartoon and sticks and Pinal has
overlaid
on top of each other but if I go to my
active site here and I show it as sticks
it's going to erase any other overlaid
representation so watch while I do this
ready 1 2 3 and it chopped out pieces of
the cartoon so the active site no longer
looks like it's connected to the protein
and some of some parts are going to be
missing little pieces of themselves you
you won't see that these amino acids are
actually involved in the alpha helix and
so when you're doing the show command
you probably want to show everything on
top of it you see how that alpha helix
just came back really nicely well I hope
you found this tutorial useful and that
you learned something we're ending on
just a little movie we can make movies
in pi mole of our beautiful active site
rotating in 3d space don't forget to
check the video description for links to
my code so you can model even faster